alors j'ai pas mon pied de caméra mais
on va se débrouiller je veux absolument
faire cette vidéo je n'avais pas prévu
de faire celle ci en vrai et ben voilà
pour aujourd'hui mon pied de caméra est
un livre salut à tous je vous ai mis une
vidéo en ligne sur mon analyse
personnelle du discours d'hollande par
rapport à la prise de pouvoir de donald
trump cette analyse comme toute analyse
n'engage que moi avec ce que je pense
être vrai et les conclusions que j'en
tire et en fin de vidéo je faisais une
hypothèse sur la manière d'écrire cette
analyse politique là ce qui n'avait rien
à voir avec les signaux non verbaux et
je faisait également référence avec
humour au fait qu'ils avaient eu qu'une
led de préparé par l'elysée pour les
félicitations suite à tout ça et s'est
passé quelque chose de cool trois
personnes qui sont amies qui ont
beaucoup d'eux mêmes centres d'intérêt
que moi qui se croisent survenue contre
argumenter la vidéo alors déjà comme je
disais j'ai plutôt la chance d'avoir une
communauté coup les bienveillantes dire
que c'est pas parti en live c'était un
échange un vrai échange
et c'était déjà arrivé dans le début
d'année avec quelqu'un d'autre j'avais
proposé de faire une vidéo ensemble et
il l'a pas vraiment donné de suite
puisque pas très grave d'ailleurs c'est
un choix tout à fait respectable et
pourquoi j'avais proposé une vidéo parce
que dans les commentaires et par écrit
c'est souvent redondants ont dit à peu
près la même chose ça se cherche au mot
près comme s'il y avait un espèce de
combat en fait est il malgré les smileys
le moindre mot peut être très mal
interprétée comme je voulais c'est voir
là par exemple ou plutôt ici je pense
que veulent insérez ici paris ces trois
personnes deux d'entre eux ont une
chaîne que je suis d'ailleurs je suis
abonné à ces deux chaînes la
signification et le mythologue je crois
je vous mettrais un lien dans la
description et j'ai eu le même genre de
discussions mais avec quelqu'un que je
connais un petit peu plus sur facebook
et comme à chaque fois depuis le début
de l'année quand ça se passe je propose
qu'on fasse une vidéo ensemble l'idée
n'étant pas de dire si j'ai raison ou si
j'ai tort l'idée c'est de discuter
ensemble autour de ces sujets qui
apportent leur point de vue et leur
analyse et leur approche et que je
puisse apporter la mienne et que
peut-être on se retrouve sur des points
ou pas du tout en fait on n'en sait rien
mais qu'on puisse discuter ensemble et
face à la caméra je pense que ça
pourrait être très intéressant de faire
ça file mais puisque ça vous donnerai un
autre point de vue que le mien une autre
vérité que la mienne parce que j'ai pas
de vraie vérité j'ai juste ce que je
crois moi c'est ça que je vous dis à
chaque fois
et donc si quelqu'un pense différemment
peut-être linverse ou peut-être juste
différemment je crois que ça peut être
très intéressant et très important pour
vous de le voir donc je vous dise
je leur ai proposé de faire ça et pour
la première fois j'ai eu des réponses
positives
alors je sais pas trop comment ça va
s'organiser si tout le monde habite sur
paris ou pas en tout cas ce que je sais
c'est que je veux absolument vous faire
cette vidéo avant la fin de l'année si
d'autres personnes veulent y participer
alors forcément faut arriver avec autre
chose qu'un avis c'est à dire des
connaissances
une argumentation et c'est quelque chose
d'assez construit ça peut être des
personnes comme la personne que j'avais
contacté qui faisait partie du milieu
des et éthicien et c'est pour parler
aussi tout ça dans mon approche du
mentalisme en spectacle on peut parler
tout et ça va forcément être cool et
donc si je vous fais avoue cette vidéo
ce soir c'est déjà pour vous dire si
vous avez lu les commentaires ou pas ce
qui est en train de se passer mais ça me
permet si jamais il y avait le moindre
doute à ce sujet un jour que je ne
prétends pas avoir une vérité absolue me
place pas comme comme maître de quoi que
ce soit surtout sur le domaine délicat
du non-verbal parce que c'est bien que
du non verbal quand par là on parle pas
des techniques de mémoire d' influence
psychologique ou ce genre de choses on
parle toujours là à chaque fois c'est
sûr le non verbal
donc ça me permet de vous conseiller de
garder toujours l'esprit critique de
chercher d'autres sources et même
contradictoires c'est toujours très
intéressant et de vous annoncer qu'on
devrait faire ça sur la chaîne
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à liker si cette idée là
vous plaît qu'on fasse pas ça pour rien
non plus vous pouvez aussi me dire en
commentaire s'il ya des personnes en
particulier que vous aimeriez invités à
cette discussion là je vous promets rien
à part de les contacter au minimum et
d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils
viennent n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à
la chaîne avant de partir si ce n'est
pas déjà fait rendez vous de demain à
17h châu
m